foreign I think what's been so beautiful
to see over the course of these films is
how our relationship has has grown and
changed
we talked about our characters and where
they would be at this point in the story
Bianca and Adonis having having a child
and and what the family in the future
was going to look like moving forward
with Amara
qualities from her mom and
Mark feels strong she feels Brave Amara
makes Adonis a better man a better
father better husband their dreams
really deepen for a person that you've
made so I think Amara is a real gift in
that way
this film is really about family
[Music]
I think they're constantly pushing each
other to be the best versions of
themselves
[Music]